[Music]
if minecraft is many things to many
people it is a creative tool it is a
game to get immersed in it is anything
that you would want it to be raised
raising is one of the key innovations
that we think is next from minecraft our
tech gives us that custom flavor for
each block you can't see anywhere else
guys this is so cool
I mean Minecraft VR 4k graphics Wow
it's almost like the real thing that bit
of my sword go
damn these graphics are so good this is
gonna change mine crank but just like
real Minecraft there's creepers oh man
yeah I've always wanted to do that yeah
hello let me try one thing this is so
real oh wait it's a woman sorry sorry
sorry sorry sorry
I would never hurt the woman harassment
is not a game early hunters dog just
guesses I'm a video game guys doesn't
mean I'm gonna change my own moral my
own beliefs and what I believe what's
wrong with you are you gimme gimme yeah
bit shame on you
she fainted wake up
Oh sir you must help me this lady is
unconscious
[Music]
kiss-kiss yes now are we a little bit
excuse me I'm playing frickin mind crap
get out of my room
you'll pay for this woman or not oh my
god yes sit the Frick down girl I got
the freaking troika
I feel its power surging incredible name
you have strong legs I admired them I
admire them alive
now
excuse me
excuse me excuse me stop shame on you
oh let's get it right in there no no
wake up he's dead it was you
[Music]
this is just like Minecraft
open wide you like that how do you feel
when you got moves
[Music]
I like that you're special you're
special and don't let anyone ever say
you're not follow me is that good sir
really good very nice
let's see Oh what is that what is this
oh I'm sorry bro Bing bong Bing Bing
bong Bing bong Bing Bing bong this is an
old family tradition actually we do this
back at home in Sweden so we get people
really really drunk and then we get to
Minecraft X and did we shop chop shop
okay here we go shop you have to get it
in one stroke oh there it is lucky win
there hello you're a lucky one so
someone has too much fiber in their diet
and sorry yeah let go let go of my fine
you win this round yes this is good
yes good wait oh oh
I will find you another one don't worry
you just make sure you shop and just
chop chop
why don't come up and a little bit of
flex tape I'm crying
he's beautiful
are you happy
hello no I thought finally I create the
greatest specimen on planet there will
be more legs
there will be more I'll find them and
I'll get them for my collection will be
complete oh oh no it's a woman sorry
sorry III don't fight I don't fight I'm
serious I don't do this I would never
hurt a woman it's my number one priority
don't ever go close to me ever
she went close and it guns what sir guns
Oh God
they try to do sneaky don't run don't
run don't run or else your friend goes
to buy buy land I'm serious I'm serious
our 55 said minecraft gold in cash
the little to me at my location do not
come near me or your friend will shoot
what's your name Bing bong yo your fan
bingbing goes Bing bong okay I made it
fifty thousand what's run Bing bong
don't worry when you're safe with me oh
that's a warning
don't worry Bing bong we have to run
Bing bong we have to run the cops are
coming don't worry Bing bong it's just
it's just for show hey step aside step
aside back off or bing bang or bing bong
is going to not be so happy you'll get
we're gonna marry each other
drop it a minute
[Music]
Oh God
what have I done my mission wasn't to
harm people it was just to chop off
their legs
I'm a monster Oh what have I become back
to my roots I'm gonna build a house and
I'm gonna retire with Bing bong
I got a build Bing bong a grave oh my
god
are you serious oh can I give it to Bing
bong Captain America shield minecraft
shield oh this is the most swedish
experience of all time I have Mjolnir
[Music]
[Applause]
I am now ready for any enemy Hey
put this on I don't want to see your
bald face put it on put it on that's
epic sorry
I will never perfect I'm still a day
who's awesome what everyone go hello
wake up wake up hello what is this Norse
God okay Who am I fighting oh well that
was easy
I feel like we've learned something here
today the life isn't just about playing
and having fun it's also serious
sometimes you have to take things
serious
[Music]
he's running
he's trying to escape
nice Swedish stance
[Music]
ah I'm done
well you haven't tried to pursue Malita
density perhaps for 50 million our
troops much Maya I can't do it I am now
just now it's still relevant just
download it